raï était de retour dans les yvelines
l'ancien footballeur emblématique du pg
qui habitait à croissy sur seine a été
reçu à l'hôtel du département à
versailles dans le cadre du trophée gol
de letra un tournoi caritatif organisé
cette année au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour récolter
des dons en faveur des enfants
défavorisés au brésil pour le soutenir
le département lui a remis un chèque de
dix mille euros c'est essentiel pour
qu'ils puissent continuer à l'étrave à
20 en plus des vingt mille enfants et
jeunes sont déjà déjà passé on espère
continuer dans le moment au même rythme
dès qu'il fera quelque chose on sera pas
loin de pouvoir l'aider parce qu on a
toujours cru en cet homme et on le croit
encore aujourd'hui dès lors qu'il ait
troqué ses tenues de footballeur pour
celles d'ambassadeur au grand coeur le
lendemain un parfum de brésil envahi le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
avec au programme des spectacles de
batucada et de capoeira proposées par
les clubs locaux
ce sont ensuite les tambours du
collectif ultra du paris saint germain
qui ont investi les tribunes pour
soutenir haye
les supporters n'ont pas hésité à
remettre un chèque de 2000 euros à la
fondation
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on va voir
l'association de rails et voilà on est
présent à chaque année voilà c'est
important pour nous sur le terrain de
foot c'est les aficionados du psg ont pu
revoir des joueurs qui ont marqué les
travées du parc des princes comme
laurent fournier eric rabesandratana ou
bernard mendy
tout simplement parce que c'est une
bonne initiative j'ai été content que
rahim appel à un ancien de la maison et
c'est pour une bonne cote au travers
d'un match on arrive à récolter des
fonds à rassembler aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de personnes
mais c'est vrai que là ce sont bien sûr
bien c'est pas grand chose c'est qu'une
journée on donne de nous sur un terrain
on se retrouve également entre ancien
footballeur autre ancien parisien
une dizaine d'anciennes gloires qui ont
eu du mal à terminer la rencontre
physiquement mais l'essentiel était
ailleurs pour cette quinzième édition
très productive
c'est tous les bus étaient atteints pour
viser les choses des sociétés et les
partenaires et collaborateurs aussi qu'à
l'intégration
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
trophée gol de letra hirai pourrait
revenir l'année prochaine au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines